lo que haremos en este vídeo es obtener
más práctica escribiendo números muy
grandes de diferentes maneras por
ejemplo supongamos que nos dan este
número no lo diré en voz alta propósito
bien y lo que quiero que hagamos es que
pensemos en cómo podríamos escribir este
número en palabras los invito a que
pausa en el vídeo y lo intenten ustedes
solos antes de que lo hagamos juntos
incluso escribe con palabras este número
en un papel como lo escribir y es bueno
ahora sí hagámoslo juntos pero antes de
escribir este número con palabras quiero
que pongamos las cifras en una tabla de
valor posicional porque eso nos ayudará
a identificar qué representa cada dígito
vamos a ver como una especie de
recordatorio si no están familiarizados
con las tablas de valor posicional
existe una columna para cada uno de los
valores posicional es desde la unidad
hasta las decenas centenas millares y
decenas de millares en este caso tenemos
decenas de millar
pues colocamos las unidades de millar en
esta parte y le pongo una s porque esto
significa decenas de millar es decir
decenas de miles y aquí unidades de
millar es decir de miles después tenemos
la posición de las centenas aquí van las
decenas y finalmente las unidades
entonces comencemos de este lado cuántas
unidades tenemos bueno como pueden ver
tenemos cinco unidades y cuantas decenas
tenemos aquí lo podemos ver cero ahora
cuántas centenas tenemos tenemos seis
centenas y cuantos millares bueno
podemos ver que en esa posición tenemos
dos millares y finalmente cuántos diez
miles tenemos o mejor dicho decenas de
millar aquí podemos ver que tenemos ocho
decenas de millar ahora que tenemos esta
representación escribamos el número con
palabras aunque no tienen que hacer todo
esto siempre solamente quise asegurar
de que revisemos cada forma posible de
pensar en esto entonces podemos decir
que tenemos 80 mil es 2000 es 600 y 5
unidades pero no es así como las
personas lo dicen con palabras lo común
es decir 82 1605 vamos a escribir cuando
escribimos un número con palabras la
forma convencional es colocando comas en
el mismo lugar donde se encuentran las
comas entre las cifras como en este caso
entonces vamos a expresar esta parte
como 82.000 lo escribiré 82.000 coma
coma y después tenemos 600 pero no
tenemos decenas así que solamente es 605
pero si tuviéramos un 1 aquí sería 615
pero esto es 605 lo escribiré de otro
color azul entonces 82 mil y después 600
y listo hagamos otro ejemplo ahora
escribiré un número con palabras y
quiero que ustedes lo escriban en cifras
el número es cincuenta mil 631
quiero que escriban esto en la forma
convencional que es simplemente
escribirlo como un número y poniendo las
comas en donde deban de ir pausa en el
vídeo y vean si pueden hacerlo vamos a
ver la primera parte es 50.000 y la
podemos escribir como mejor primero
pongamos las posiciones esta es la
posición de las decenas de millar
después unidades de millar centenas
decenas y unidades
entonces para escribir 50.000 vamos a
ponerlo así podemos decir que tenemos
cinco decenas de millar o cincuenta
millares y después nos dicen 631
entonces a los seiscientos los colocamos
aquí y después 31 es literalmente 31 o
si lo quieren ver de otra manera son
tres decenas y una unidad 31 y claro nos
falta poner la coma en la misma posición
recuerden que la coma se pone después de
cada tres cifras
esta es la primera vez que hacen esto
empiecen a contar desde la derecha y la
ponemos entre las centenas y los
millares ahí lo tiene esto es lo mismo
que 50 mil 631 este es el número escrito
de forma convencional con cifras